[Musique]
bonjour la réunion de bonjour le monde
comment il les a toutes ces zones les
biens - les mieux alors oh ça ne l'est
aujourd'hui ne l'est à bagatelle sainte
suzanne où on va aller voir charles
mamaï charlie près partie confiture
charlie prépare des petits bonds des
petits produits comme ça là un mehdi pas
autre plus vient elle de voir comment
les bons bien vient
[Musique]
au mans il est chargé sa va ça va ça va
super on va déjà mais aussi d'accueil à
nous pas de souci dis moi bah déjà où
est ce qu'on est
et qu'est ce que tu fais alors donc la
nôtre l'est dans mon petit mon petit
paradis donc sainte suzanne bagatelle
l'atelier de transformation des savanes
la fournaise et ce matin atelier
transformation de l'ananas atelier
transformation d'ananas et ben écoute tu
sais quoi on va voir tout ça on va voir
tout ça et puis on va parler d'un petit
truc après assez spécial aussi on y va
[Musique]
alors dit moi
donc là je suppose que c'est alors là
c'est un petit ananas qui monte aux roms
de savannah qui est un petit produit
c'est l'un des premiers produits que
j'ai inventé d'accord et donc là
aujourd'hui on est en train de le
préparer
pour paul livrés et préparer les fêtes
avec dix mois alors bon on en a ce
produit là donc ça c'est un ascète qui
me fait penser à la nasse exprimant
rouge
alors maintenant alors quid de tous fait
ouvrir à d'autres choses d'autres
créations la création va pas aller là on
va passer aux choses sérieuses donc
après on a toute une gamme de produits
d'épicerie fine donc venu partie sucré
donc avec une crème de patates douces et
la vanille donc qui ressemble un petit
peu à la crème de marron pour les
amateurs ils crament de patates douces
au chocolat après on est sur toutes les
confitures ananas mangue mon miel qui
ont été médaillés au concours général de
paris
mandrichi qui cette année a eu prix 2e
prix donc 1 médaille d'argent sur
concours général agricole montagne on
goûte à nous après on est sûr sur tout
type de transformation de fruits et
légumes à la réunion voc a prôné sur la
partie sale et donc entre tacles un
aspirant le bafing le tillac margose le
citron pays
emblème là ma faim après pouffer salive
aux mines encore mieux un petit pâte de
piments rouges des maisons à l'ancienne
toujours et je dis moi
les léopards la main de tous les
produits transformés et
il suppose que c'est du du local tout
est fait localement tous produits
viennent la réunion ça c'est que des
saveurs qui sont ici le soleil le sol ne
tient pas si on a cessé quand c'est
qu'on a envie de fées fait voyager nous
nous voilà l'idée c'est de prendre la
réunion et emmène là bas dans mes
compositions
le seul truc que mal a pas le droit de
mettre dedans la loi de suppléments lui
les jambes c'est le vinaigre et ne peut
pas mettre l'amour déçu au ces mais ont
[Musique]
donc là avec avec eric laval qu'on
présente plus cher un collègue de
travail et puis amis voilà c'est lui qui
perd la voix très vite lorsqu'il ya un
micro et une caméra c'est bizarre et
parle je suis moins à l'aise
la cuisine était sûr voilà c'est ça et
c'est un grand chef cuisinier amateur
delà de la gastronomie réunionnaise et
du coup là on est sur la préparation de
l'assassinât d'un spi montait au rhum de
savannah assez l'ananas victoria tout le
monde a bien reconnu dans wii 2 2
arsenal produits qualité ici donc après
il reste plus grand chose juste un petit
savoir faire le produit le produit
magnifique déjà petit savoir faire
ouais ouais ouais bravo bravo aux gens
qui sont qu'ils ont la main dans la
terre d'abord et puis après nous on
intervient sur des produits déjà dû être
bonne gamme donc c'est plus facile pour
nous de travailler des produits bonne
gamme que voilà donc un petit coup un
petit clin d'oeil aux gens qui ont les
manades
[Musique]
et maintenant on est toujours dans mon
labo mais à côté de florence est en
train de préparer
la matière première est donc la patate
douce patates douces d'accord qui sera
toujours dans le sud au tampon patates
et le son du bon et donc c'est pas
préparé voilà donc là c'est pour
préparer une crème de patates de ce
chocolat
ce qui est génial c'est que hunan a
aussi tous côtés bon maintenant une loi
patates douces manioc et ira tout de
suite ces prochains moins à l'époque
mais mais ep et pour le coup c'était
général c'est qu'il revisite ça on remet
au goût du jeu à des anciens des anciens
anciens légumes féculents soit quoi et
ça pour moi mais trouve super parce que
il achève de donne une un cachet un
cachet un cachet typique du coup on est
fier de cette crème de patate douce
parce que toujours on est les seuls à le
faire est d'arriver à une ressemblance
au niveau gustatif
on va se rapprocher de la cram demande
mais il faut qu'il arrête de parler
comme ça parce que - ma faim nous sommes
justement nous sautent tampon devant là
bas et la maaf un mélo la fin à ce que
la dynamique et rapide n'ont rien parce
qu'on est prêt ça nous a fait ça ne
participe à bastia ça au salon de
chocolat bon mes patates douces
s'imagine oms a fait beaucoup de fautes
at 12 bana là-bas au chocolat rhinos a
fait mais vous nous faites vous teaser
la maman va reprendre après accessible
mais restait l apo souligner qu'on
diffère aussi matin me lève des
dernières manifs ausy qui la main
douceur à jour ne remplit il faut la
faune r mes propres mondes case à terre
mais sans mon copain les nazis mais koné
p bon coup et mary monde des médias ou
[Musique]
de purée de patates douces
alors là je suis en train de préparer le
maintien qui va partir à la marmite avec
le poids exact que j'ai besoin c'est que
la confiture c'est une science basée sur
la mathématique très précise très
précise et vraiment il faut pas dix
grammes de plus les grands de l'art est
un peu d'eau et là on va attaquer sur la
menthe peu de cette nature alors à ceux
cette préparation cette fleur de sel
vient de cas font ils s'enfoncent en
local à 100% local mais ça va donner
cette petite un petit aspect ça va
frapper la patate douce ça va lui donner
un petit coup en plus
[Musique]
oula
donc là le cela fait beau et émulation
exact exact à la température qu'on voit
ou qu'on voulait il me disait que 1 du
druide plus finir
la recette est foirée leur moitié pauvre
gamine et voilà donc là on incorpore la
patate douce dans le sucre à température
donc là on est sur la fleur de sel le
citron kaffir muzaton caviar
mais
et là on va vous remets le chocolat je
vais tourner
et là on voit qu'on est sur un liquide
produit kg et crémeux
[Musique]
mais c'est terrible assez bon remplir
les poches bon matelas et on va te
donner une poche aussi pour en clair oui
voilà écoute
et
joue les petites meufs en crochet
il
m
comment la rive alors est-ce que je vous
la levée wadi thiam ça fait de confiture
compagnie ou alors mais suppose que vu
le petit habits et les petites les
différents petite médaille là mais je
pourrais ce que c'est un métier qu'il a
choisi et où le passionné alors c'est le
mix des deux baies donc formation
professionnelle donc brevet de
technicien agricole que me l'a jamais
exploité du coup me réveille matin midi
il faut que mes spots ce que ce que me
connaît bien faire donc il faisait un
peu des abeilles mais faisait un peu de
produits transformés comme ça juste pour
la passion cette passion la voile a
transformé en activité professionnelle
pour pur amusement un peu sortir un peu
du rien de la journée 2-2
cherchez une activité pour bouger quoi
donc du coup je me suis dit la petite
cuisine familiale
pourquoi pas prendre un peu de piment la
pâte un peu de mal à goes by l'habite si
jacques et tous les produits que je me
fais aujourd'hui moi s'amuse un petit
peu on va faire ça dis moi alors parce
que pour le coup donc un homme a vu
toutes ces préparations là mais on a un
truc qui appelle le faux gras vite fait
vite fait mon envie coup expliqua soit
exactement c'est quoi ces concepts de
faudra alors le faux gras c'est on va
enfin je sais pas s'il faut dire ça
comme ça mais sympa c'est un fantasme de
végétariens c'est vraiment le produit
fait de cette fin d'année a produit que
j'ai élaboré en décembre de l'année
dernière pour dans le cadre d'une
invitation que j'avais reçu une
invitation familiale pour pour une fête
de noël avec eux mais bon on attend que
végétarien on peut pas manger
tout tu feras plus foie gras votre donc
la légende disait il faudra ramener ce
que tu as toi tu as envie de manger ce
que l'on sait pas quoi faire prendre et
je n'ai rien dit moi je me lance je fais
un faux gras je vais faire le foie gras
végétarien végétalien
mais avec que des produits de la région
tous les produits donc je sors le petit
truc le faux gras aux lentilles de
cilaos qui aura cette année aussi en
vente pour les gens succès phénoménal
tous les gens qui est au top on mange en
pensant que c'est un foie gras et donc
du coup le résultat était là mais c'est
à dire au revoir parce que là on se
retrouve madame ça mange tout vaut mieux
pas arriver tôt pour déguster ah oui
quand on veut quand on veut un 8ème un
dimanche tout nouveau à la prochaine can
merci merci à vous merci tout accueil
doit travailler le coup de main les bons
pas le problème mais très choquée
nouveau trouve merci un autre
[Musique]
et voilà messieurs dames
l'émission se termine on n'est pas sorti
de l'auberge eh ben c'est terminé pour
aujourd'hui mais ne vous en faites pas
je reviendrai et j'en fais trop mais
vous savez pourquoi
parce que c'est trop c'est trop bon et
on n'est pas du tout sorti de l'auberge
ben non parce que - comme il marche dans
mon cas rock and un mât me traverse
comme ça et là tout d'un coup comme il
mange un conflit tu es de patates douces
et chocolat marmaille excusé
[Musique]